auf das schwarze quadrat folgte die
revolution in russland auf den schwarzen
greift die studentenrevolte in paris der
schwarze kreis von olivier musik geboren
hier in bayern 1944 ein jahr nach ihm
kommt natascha wodin zur welt sie wächst
auf als tochter russisch ukrainischer
eltern im nachkriegsdeutschland als
tochter einstiger zwangsarbeitern es
nach die regie und somit stigmatisiert
als displaced persons das gefühl -
zugehörig zu sein begleitet die
schriftstellerin ein leben lang und sie
verarbeitet es auch literarisch und
plötzlich findet sie wonach die immer
gesucht habt spuren ihrer familie
nun hat wurde ihnen den preis der
leipziger buchmesse gewonnen für ihren
neuen blick auf deutsche
geschichtsschreibung und eine schier
unglaubliche familiengeschichte
das sich den namen meiner mutter in die
suchmaschine des russischen internet
eintippte war nicht viel mehr als eine
spielerei ich konnte es nicht fassen ich
habe ganz lange geglaubt es muss ein
irrtum seines gibt's gar nicht dass also
diese vor 60 jahren in deutschland
gestorbene bedeutungslose junge
ukrainerin plötzlich im russischen
internet steht
jahrelang hatte natascha wodin
vergeblich nach ihrer mutter gesucht
[Musik]
wir waren kinder
meine schwester gerade erst 14 jahre alt
als sie an einem oktobertag im jahr 1956
wortlos die wohnung verließ und nicht
wiederkam
so beginnt die geschichte der
schriftstellerin natascha wodin in ihrem
buch sie kam aus mariupol erzählt sie
wie es war als kind jüdischer
immigranten nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
in deutschland aufzuwachsen
ein seltsames leben war dass ich bin als
kind im abseits geboren ich hatte
überhaupt keinen kontakt zur deutschen
ich habe das als kind nicht verstanden
also ich hab zwar irgendwie man
begriffen da gibt es noch andere
menschen und es scheint die richtige
welt zu sein und wir sind ja mir die
falsche in der deutschen schule hatte
man uns beigebracht dass die russen
deutschland überfallen
alles zerstört und den deutschen ihr
halbes land weggenommen hätten
ich saß in der hintersten reihe und die
lehrerin erzählte dass die russen ihren
verlobten die augen mit glühenden kohlen
ausgebrannt hätten alle drehten sich
nach mehr um
und ich wusste nach schulschluss würde
wieder die jagd beginnt tief unglücklich
in deutschland war auch putins mutter
die autorin weiß wenig über sie noch der
vater schwieg sein leben lang
sie hatte immer sonne sehen dass nach
einer ukraine die es nicht mehr gab aber
in der heutigen ukraine war ganz klar
konnte sie nicht leben und aber auch sie
konnte im heutigen deutschland nicht
leben
doch warum fühlte sich die mutter so
unbeachtet
natascha wodin fast immer tiefer er
fährt immer mehr
es ist ein riesiger familien plan
daraus entstanden also ich habe einst
große stammbaum bei mir an die wand
gemalt vor dem sitz ich manchmal wieso
vor der weltkarte die familie kommt aus
der küstenstadt mario pohl der klaren
von dem sie glaubte er sehr arm war vor
der revolution adelig und wohlhabend ein
onkel sogar ein berühmter opernsänger
einer
ich dachte das ist doch eigentlich ohne
familie ganz gut geht warum holst du dir
das jetzt in dein leben
diese starken negativen energien
allmählich versteht wurde ihn warum die
mutter ihre herkunft verschwieg adelige
galten in der sowjetunion als abschaum
selbst wenn sie wie die mutter niemals
die privilegien ihre herkunft genossen
hatten meine mutter hingegen kannte nur
die zerstörung dessen was ihr selbst nie
zu gute gekommen war
sie war mitten hinein geboren in den
bürgerkrieg den terror den hunger die
verfolgung ein weiteres mysterium löst
sich als diener fährt dass die mutter
als 24-jährige 1944 nach deutschland
deportiert wurde
die längste zeit meines lebens hatte ich
gar nicht gewusst er sich ein kind von
song verbreitern bin niemand hat es mir
gesagt nicht meine eltern nicht die
deutsche umwelt
vor und während des zweiten weltkriegs
rekrutierten die deutschen zwischen
sieben und elf millionen zwangsarbeiter
die unter unmenschlichen bedingungen in
der deutschen kriegsindustrie
zerschunden wurden und danach auch nie
mehr ein leben gefunden haben weil sie
repariert wurden in die sowjetunion und
dort galten sie als kollaborateure und
vaterlandsverräter leben bis zu ihrem
tod aus der gesellschaft ausgeschlossen
also die paar zwei die paar jahre
zwangsarbeit haben ihnen das leben
zerstört wo dienstbuch ist eine
aufarbeitung eine geschichte von
russlands von zwangsarbeit und der
mutter die sich 1956 ertränken
[Musik]
zurück blieben ein mann und zwei
töchtern
[Musik]